And it doesn't need to be this chronic depressed immune response.
Let's say this is taking place on a regular basis of peak.
My liver cells didn't die and it went into this rapid replication,
but no, I just went through this huge amount of stress.
You just got this letter from the IRS or you just got laid off from your job
or you're going through marital issues or something's wrong with your child
or your parent is dying.
You go through a stress. What does stress do to your body?
Stress diminishes your immune response.
Stress is a part of your sympathetic nervous system.
You fire the sympathetic response at your immune system
and your digestive tract run on your parasympathetic nervous system.
So that's the stress those things shut down and guess what?
I have a diminished immune response.
Maybe it's only for a few weeks, maybe it's only for a few months.
But that time that I have that diminished immune response by T cells
and by macrophage and lymphocytes, we're not nearly strong enough
to kill that rapidly replicated and growing cell mass.
Do you realize in order for you to have a diagnosis of cancer
by any modern methods today, it has to be in the millions of cells large?
It's that size of a pinhead of the million cells.
So you know, you have a lump under your breast.
It's in the millions and millions of cells already.
Okay, this has been going on for some time.
It didn't just happen yesterday.
Even if it's a very quick-growing cancer.
Follow me so far.
So you had a diminished immune response.
Cause this cancer just to take off.
And now even if I bring my immune system back up
but I take a whole bunch of acne, share it.
I'm doing all this right things.
You know, you play the country music song backwards
and you get your horse back and your cow back and all this stuff.
But everything starts falling in line for you
and you have a healthy immune response.
It may be too large for your immune system to kill.
Because what happens is in real life.
So in real life, every time I replicate a cell
or even normal cell metabolism in real life gives off waste.
So your cells in your body are together, right?
They're next to each other.
But there's a space in between your cells.
That's called your extracellular space.
Or your extracellular matrix is a better term for it
because it really isn't a space.
It's filled with fluid.
So it's filled with fluid that becomes very viscous
as it as wastes are dumped into there.
So how your cells respite, you could say,
they take in nutrients and then they metabolize those nutrients,
whatever that cell is going to do.
And they dump their waste into the space between the cells.
And the more it's rapidly replicating and rapidly metabolizing
as in cancer, it's going to give off an enormous amount of waste.
So that waste is very acidic.
That's why you heard said that you should
alkalize your tissue, right?
Very important.
And you may even heard the terminology that you can...
Cancer doesn't grow in an acidic environment, right?
You heard that term before?
I wasn't here for the last person speech, but it's a good term.
It's not really true, though.
Cancer creates an acidic environment.
It's rapid replication by very definition,
gives off a ton of waste into the extracellular matrix.
And that waste is very acidic.
Cancer, by itself, creates an acidic environment.
So you can be eating perfectly.
You can be doing everything possibly right.
And at that cancer, it's acidic.
I'll guarantee you.
That acidic waste becomes like an acidic slime layer
around the cancer that actually protects it
against your immune system.
So even if you do all this stuff right,
and you're doing all this immune stimulation,
your macrophages are trying to attack it
and can't even penetrate the acidic slime layer.
That's not good.
So the bigger the cancer is,
the bigger that acidic slime layer,
the harder it is to penetrate for your immune system to kill it.
So it becomes this catch-22 kind of thing, right?
And usually people aren't stressed with cancer, right?
So they go to the doctor and you have liver cancer.
And you go, typically, oh, yes!
I thought that's what I told you.
No, they go, what?
They're scared of death.
They're in this total-fier panic mode, typically, right?
So what does that do?
Your sympathetic nervous system goes through the roof.
Your parasympathetic drops into the garbage.
Your immune system goes, okay, I guess I'm not needed.
I'm going to the vacation.
And you're in trouble.
So it just perpetuates the growth of the cancer.
Now there's nothing trying to keep it at bay.
The cancer is growing like crazy now.
And you're given usually three options from the medical field, right?
So you have, we could surgically remove it.
We could radiate it.
Or we could use chemotherapy or a combination of those.
And all of those really are what are termed debalking.
You heard that term?
Debalking?
Your debalking?
The cancer.
You're trying to remove as much of it as possible.
That's what you're trying to do.
So is it always bad to do any of those?
No, not necessarily.
I mean, you've got to really think about this.
And again, the more physiology you know,
the more you really start thinking about what's actually taking place.
Maybe you're going to make a different decision than what you're under this panic mode.
And I'm going to just trust the doctor completely.
And you've got all your family members saying,
you've got to do this, you've got to do this, you've got to do this partly
because it might absolve them from any responsibility
from helping you any other way.
We'll just push you just do it the night or another.
That if it doesn't turn out right, won't it's fault?
We did everything possible.
There is another way.
Even if you choose to do some of the chemo radiation or surgery,
there is another way.
There are some inherent flaws, right?
Even doing a biopsy, there's inherent flaws.
We're going to do an edel biopsy.
Going in there, sticking an edel in there, pulling that edel out,
you spread cancer cells.
You heard that before?
Truth is though,
you've already spread a lot of cancer cells.
By the time the cancer is at the thousands of cell mass
long before it's able to be diagnosed at a CT scan,
mammogram or MRI or anything like that,
it is giving it off what are called circulating tumor cells.
Circulating tumor cells are not yet rapidly replicated cells.
They break off of the cancer, they circulate through the body,
heads their name, and they're looking for a place
to set up home and raise a family, you could say.
That's where metastasized comes in, yes.
That's where other primary tumors come in too.
They may be listed as primary tumors too.
But typically, those are true metastasis.
Here's the problem.
We're going to go in there and do a needle biopsy.
We spread it around even more.
We're going to go in there and do surgery.
We can spread it around even more.
We can't possibly see these cells.
We can only see the mass.
So we're going to take out the greatest amount of mass
in hope that we've got all the cells.
You can't know that you got all the cells.
There's other problems inherent with surgery
because when you go there and do surgery,
your body heals any injury.
I cut myself with my chains on once.
Yes, I did admit to that on camera.
No.
How my body healed that was after I took the duct tape off.
How my body healed that was sending out an enormous amount
of growth hormone.
That's how your body heals any injury.
You do surgery.
You say that enormous amount of growth hormone
to heal that surgery, right?
Growth hormone to cancer cells is like gasoline.
So there's a huge inherent danger to surgery.
So sometimes it's necessary and you have to take approaches.
I'm not saying that's not always the not wise thing to do.
I'm just saying you got to think about this.
Well, what's our other approach?
We're going to do chemotherapy.
So what does chemotherapy do?
Chemotherapy is a very strong poison that kills
rapidly replicating cells.
Well, that's great.
You said cancer was rapidly replicated.
So we want to take chemotherapy because it'll kill the rapidly replicating cells.
Problem.
Well, there's other cells in your body that are rapidly replicating.
Like your hair follicles.
That's why your hair falls out when you do chemotherapy.
Also, your immune system.
That's why your immune system gets shut out.
Shut down what you do, chemotherapy.
Well, that's kind of bad because I thought you said
we need an immune system to heal cancer.
That's a really bad one.
The other really bad thing about doing chemotherapy,
even if we could take a magic one and wave it over you
and all your cancer is gone, is that the truth is,
chemotherapy, radiation, and surgery do nothing
for circulating tumor cells.
And like I said, you have circulating tumor cells
long before you even have a diagnosis of cancer.
They're everywhere.
And what is keeping them at bay?
What is keeping them from rapidly replicating at this point?
The immune system.